a theme song welcoming the world to
watch the 2022 winter games while the
olympic torch makes its way through
beijing
china has promised to deliver a safe and
splendid global event but achieving this
isn't going to be easy
a nationwide outbreak of covert 19 and
record cases abroad are testing its zero
tolerance pandemic strategy participants
are greeted with helpers in hazmat suits
and must undergo a rigorous testing
regime before and during the event
those found to be positive are
immediately quarantined and could miss
out on competing there's been a lot of
athletes that are testing positive right
now and it's scary because you put in
four years
since the last games you know johnny put
in 24 years to get here and for all of
that to go to waste in the last week
last couple days it would be a tragedy
and so that's always kind of on your
mind and it is stressful
tickets won't be sold to the chinese
public instead spectators will be
hand-picked by authorities
this will be the second olympics to take
place during the coronavirus pandemic
but measures here are much stricter than
during the tokyo games participants are
sealed off in a closed loop system the
road lane just below me is restricted to
games vehicles only and local residents
have been warned to stay away even in
the event of a crash or breakdown
the heavy-handed measures have led to an
olympic atmosphere unlike any other but
for beijing the message is clear there's
not going to be the great crowds you're
not going to have the
tourism boost
that would have accompanied something
like this
and so for
beijing what they want to show the world
is that they're able to carry on
regardless of how difficult situations
become
difficulties also include criticism of
china's human rights record and
diplomatic boycotts by the united states
canada britain and australia
chinese officials have dismissed this as
political grandstanding but analysts say
china's president is eager to avoid
further embarrassment during the event
if he does not get the game happening
as expected
then it will be quite a bit of a slap in
the face
it's not a
fatal punch
in any sense but it will be very
embarrassing for xi jinping
chinese rights activists living in the
capital say they've been visited by
authorities and warned to stay silent
during the olympics
within the bubble the ioc says athletes
are free to express their views outside
of formal events or ceremonies
but organizers say those who break
chinese laws with behavior or speech
that is against the olympic spirit will
face certain punishment
katrina u al-jazeera beijing